♪♪
DIRECTOR TYLER HAYWARD
We now have first person intel
from inside the
Westview anomaly.
JIMMY WOO
What are we looking at here?
Is it an alternate reality?
Time travel?
DARCY LEWIS
It's a sitcom.
JIMMY WOO
Starring two Avengers?
DARCY LEWIS
It's a working theory.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well, I know the apron is a bit much,
dear, but I am doing
my best to blend in!
♪♪
AGNES
Hello, dear!
Hiya, kid!
Hi, kiddo!
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Life moves pretty fast out in the suburbs.
VISION
I think something's wrong here.
AGNES
[Laughing]
Should we just
take it from the top?
JIMMY WOO
Wanda! Wanda!
WANDA MAXIMOFF
I don't know how any of this started.
VISION
What is outside of Westview?
♪♪
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Yeah, I'm not sure what that's about.
It's probably just a
case of the Mondays. Am I right?
♪♪
WANDA MAXIMOFF
[Gasps]
Is this really happening?
VISION
Yes, my love.
JIMMY WOO
Are you crying?
DARCY LEWIS
I'm invested!